die höhle der löwen die einzige sendung
für die sich lohnt den fernseher
einzuschalten ding in die elfte staffel
und das heißt es gibt wieder neue
produkte die wir unter die lupe nehmen
können ich wünsche euch viel spaß mit
folge 5 von dichteste der löwen produkte
ohio war habe ich euch warten lassen und
es tut mir schrecklich leid das ganze
lag aber nicht an mir sondern
tatsächlich daran dass die produkte die
wir heute testen so brandneu sind dass
viele von ihnen noch gar nicht auf dem
markt waren als die folgen rauskamen und
genau das ist auch der richtige
stichpunkt für das erste produkt auf
dass wir tatsächlich am längsten warten
das ganze heißt es ab und die firma gibt
es tatsächlich schon ein bisschen länger
das eigentliche konzept sind springseile
mit austauschbaren bändern in
verschiedenen gewichtsklassen um sein
training dem gewünschten ziel anzupassen
in der sendung ging es aber vorrangig um
ein neues produkt das wir jetzt hier vor
uns liegen haben die austauschbaren
bänder sind geblieben es ist aber noch
eine menge neuer kam dazu gekommen und
sie wollten 200.000 euro für zehn
prozent ihrer firmenanteile was ein
firmenwert von zwei millionen euro
machen würde bekommen haben sie keinen
deal wir schauen uns das produkt
gemeinsam an sondern ist merkt das
hochwertig also jetzt so ein
magnetverschluss dran das ganze kostet
allerdings auch 99 euro und das sie ist
das connected und wie der name schon
sagt gibt es eine connection zu machen
es gibt eine eigene app mit der wir das
band mit unserem handy verbinden können
und verschiedene trainingseinheiten
ausprobieren können der mechanismus
funktioniert tatsächlich sehr gut wir
haben hier öffnung hier pins die in die
öffnung kommen die werden verdreht
zueinander eingesteckt ist gedreht und
das band ist fest also seilspringen
findet ihr entwickelten vortaten
anwendungen ohne die waren alle hellauf
begeistert anders kann man das nicht
sagen
[Musik]
also app heruntergeladen aufgemacht die
griffe verbunden hat wirklich anderthalb
minuten gedauert hat wunderbar
funktioniert also wirklich das muss ich
sagen das war eine absolute eins plus
mit sternchen in der app haben jetzt
eine menge aus wahlmöglichkeiten
zwischen verschiedenen workout wir
starten mit dem einfachen home basiert
oben rechts an das bedeutet ich hoffe
dass er gleich mit dem springseil genau
schrecken wird die viele jobs wir
gemacht haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als erstes land will man mit dem seil
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also tatsächlich es ist unheimlich
anstrengend und ich habe sogar gerade
ein ziemlich leichtes band dran die app
funktioniert super es gibt eine menge
work outs also ich bin wirklich
begeistert ich war richtig skeptisch für
mich ein absolutes wenige produkte
jahrhundert euro sind viel aber die
qualität ist super die lager hier drin
sind unheimlich gutes leo gestern
aufgefallen
also wirklich eins der
verschlussmechanismus funktioniert auch
super das ist ein produkt wie ich es mir
vorstelle von höhle der löwen also
wirklich 18 nächstes produkt nummer zwei
des heutigen test kann ich euch hier
leider gar nicht zeigen denn es ist viel
zu groß oder zu klein oder doch
eigentlich passend für jeden kunden
genau das ist nämlich das konzept von
nike ist ein tisch bzw eine firma die
ausziehbare möbel vorrangig ausziehbare
tische herstellt eine sache machen sie
aber anders um deutlich besser als die
ausziehbaren tischel ihr bis dato kennt
eigentlich sieht man zwei platten
auseinandergelebt eine extra platte in
den tischreihen und habe dann einen
längeren tisch weil aik sieht das ganz
anders aus sie haben ein patent ein
europaweiter patent sogar für einen
lamellen mechanismus wo kein extra teil
in den tisch eingesetzt werden kann
sondern man komplett bedenkenlos einfach
so den tisch auf und zuziehen kann wie
eine ziehharmonika sie wollten 350.000
euro und waren bereit dafür zehn prozent
ihrer firma abzugeben was einen film
wert von 3,5 millionen euro bedeutet und
ob es gerechtfertigt waren dass sie
keinen deal bekommen haben dass schauen
uns jetzt gemeinsam an
[Musik]
im prinzip so einfach wie genial ich
habe euch ja schon erklärt wie es
funktioniert und jetzt schauen uns aber
an ob es tatsächlich so gut funktioniert
wie die gründer das sagt leben wir hier
einfach drücken und das funktioniert
tatsächlich und dazu der größte pro
punkt für diesen tisch ist dass ich
finde dass er unheimlich gut aussieht
wirklich eine absolute 10 10 ich kann
mir tatsächlich vorstellen für meine
nächste wohnung die bald auch auf diesem
kanal hier thema wird mich für diesen
tisch zu entscheiden ich mir vorstellen
kann dass viele leute auch ein paar von
euch nicht immer einen riesigen tisch
brauchen das aber trotzdem schön ist ein
zu haben wenn dann doch mal besser da
sind der hier ist von
wirklich sehr klein ist auf acht
personen wenn noch zwei leute vor kopf
kommen und dann sogar 14 das gefällt mir
wirklich
absolute zehn von zehn produktnummer 3
gibt es leider wieder nicht auszupacken
das ganze hat aber eigentlich ziemlich
positiven grund es geht nämlich endlich
mal nur um software das ganze nennt sich
fans und ist eine weitere dating die
einen etwas anderen ansatz verfolgt
gesucht haben sie 125000 euro für 30
prozent bekommen haben sie von carsten
maschmeyer und georg kofler 200.000 euro
für 49 prozent ihrer firma was ein
firmenwert von
408.000 163 euro macht
das stimmt dann finde ich das so witzig
ein ungerader firmen wird auch das war
ein produkt wegen dem wir warten mussten
der release der app war vor zwei oder
drei tagen also bin ich auch mal sehr
gespannt ob sie tatsächlich schon nutzer
finden konnte eine sache die ich so mal
einwerfen wollte ich finde das ziemlich
doof mit dem produkt zu höhle der löwen
zu gehen das noch nicht rallye ist wenn
die sendung ausgestrahlt wird also
gerade bei software kostenloser software
oder kostenlos herunterzuladen das hat
natürlich die beste werbung wenn die
leute auf dem sofa direkt während der
sendung das ding runter laden können und
testen können für uns natürlich auch
doof weil wir müssen mit dem video
warten also mach das bitte in zukunft
anders das finde ich doof der ansatz der
app ist tatsächlich etwas anders man hat
die app quasi die ganze zeit im
hintergrund auf seinem handy laufen ist
draußen unterwegs und wird
benachrichtigt wenn eine passende person
gefunden wurde wenn sie gefunden wird
wird man benachrichtigt und hat dann
fünf minuten zeit ein spontanes
persönliches treffen auszumachen
beziehungsweise mit der person zu
schreiben was eigentlich ziemlich cool
ist das ganze spontan um persönliche
treffen ein bisschen einfacher machen
und langes warten auf eine antwort
vermeiden weil man eben nur fünf minuten
zeit hat ich lasse mir die app jetzt mal
runter machen sich auf die suche nach
der großen liebe schaue wie gut das
funktioniert und werde euch dann
erzählen wie und ob mein date gelaufen
ist so sind jetzt in der stadt unterwegs
und probieren über tanz mein nächstes
date zu finden also nach wie vor wenn
ich auf events drücke keine eigenen
events du hast noch keine begegnungen
ich hab jetzt schon seit zwei tagen an
wir gehen jetzt aktiv in den park um
potenzielle da irgendwie die erste
begegnung zu finden aber ich wage zu
bezweifeln dass die app tatsächlich
viele nutzer hat weil sie wirklich
wirklich lange zeit gebraucht haben um
die apps veröffentlichen und wenn's im
park in köln mitten in der innenstadt
nicht funktioniert dann ist der tod
also in meinem suchbereich wo ich gerade
stehe ist der achter war ja der
grüngürtel also da wo eine menge leute
stehen auf den wiesen sitzen wir haben
sehr gutes wetter es kommt niemand es
kommt niemand und die ich läuft ja auch
schon seit drei tagen und ich habe und
es rein gar nichts passiert also leider
ein leasing produkt ziemlich doof weil
das geld was sie in der sendung abholen
wollten wäre für marketing gewesen die
sendung ist natürlich das beste
marketing oder monate nachdem die
sendung ausgestrahlt wird erst die
fertige app zu releasen ist echt ein
bisschen blöd aber die jungs und mädels
haben es ja mit sicherheit auch nicht
extra gemacht sondern es ging nicht
schneller und das begrenzte budget also
tut es mir wirklich leid für sie das
eine coole idee aber leider ein losing
produkt zumindest jetzt gerade noch auf
das nächste produkt freue ich mich ganz
besonders ist dreht sich um net beweis
eine ziemlich coole initiative und noch
cooler dass sie den deal auch bekommen
haben die hatten nämlich 90.000 euro für
15 prozent an gefragt die sie dann auch
von carsten maschmeyer und nils lagerung
bekommen haben und was sich hinter
diesem namen verbirgt erzähle ich euch
jetzt ach so außerdem habe ich vergessen
zu sagen dass nico rosberg auch noch
10.000 euro gespendet hat ja einfach so
weil in ihrem mann ist ihr als zuschauer
im internet wisst ja ziemlich genau was
sich hier im internet alles abspielt und
das ist nicht immer alles nur friede
freude eierkuchen ist und vor allem dass
viele leute irgendwie das gefühl haben
dass das hier rechtsfreier raum ist was
nicht der fall ist sie wird beleidigt es
werden schlechte bewertungen geschrieben
ist werden markenrechte verletzt das
internet ist kein rechtsfreier raum und
netz beweist soll abhilfe schaffen das
ganze vernünftig zu dokumentieren aber
was können sie eigentlich alles
dokumentiert ziemlich viel auf das ganze
aber funktioniert wie es funktioniert
wie gut es funktioniert das schauen uns
jetzt mal gemeinsam ich befinde mich
jetzt schon auf der website und direkt
hier auf der startseite sehen wir
kostenlos sichern für betroffene das
schauen wir uns an das bedeutet
irgendwann hat uns geben was im internet
geschrieben dass uns nicht passt wir
wollen möglichst schnell auf die website
wollen möglichst schnell was sicher da
habe ich mir einfach mal dieses futter
profile rausgesucht kann hier jetzt
alles eintippen die zu sichernde website
meine e-mail-adresse starten die
sicherung und dann sollte wenn alles
funktioniert in den nächsten paar
minuten eine mail beim eintreffen in der
hoffentlich der gesamte account
gesichert ist und wir alles mit genauem
time stamp so haben dass es vor gericht
gegen diesen twitter user verwenden
können unter beweis ist angekommen ich
schau rein ich treffe ihn wir sehen das
profil von drexler wir sind diesen
screenshot url abfrage zeitpunkt
und nach der ersten seite ich habe das
ganze nämlich vor ein paar tagen schon
mal getestet ist es nicht möglich mehr
als die erste seite von einem twitter
profil zu sichern was völliger müll ist
ja dafür gibt sie browser extension die
wird gleich auch noch testen für eine
schnelle beweissicherung schnelle und
unkomplizierte beweissicherung bringt
das allerdings gar nichts weiter unten
auf der website finden wir allerdings
das eigentliche produkt quasi hinter
einer paywall man muss dafür bezahlen
für die sicherung privater webseiten
können betroffene ebenso die
kostenpflichtige browser extension
erwerben und genau das machen wir jetzt
bevor wir aber irgendwas benutzen können
müssen wir es kaufen beweis pakete zehn
euro für einen net beweis zehn euro für
einen beweis finde ich tatsächlich schon
hab ich gerade wenn man daran denkt dass
viele jüngere leute im internet
unterwegs sind unter 18 mann wild
schnell machen zahlungsmethoden für
online-zahlungen hat man potenziell
nicht aber was soll's dieser service
muss aufgeben wofür bezahlen
hiervon section has been cancelled das
ist dass das hier ist jetzt nur die
auftragsbestätigung ich schwöre ich
bekomme das nicht hin ungültiger code
doch super ich bin 22 jahre alte nutze
seit über 12 jahren das internet mehr
ist es nicht möglich den kauf
abzuschließen
es ist also nicht möglich die websites
zu sichern ich finde dass kompletter
müll es kann sein dass das tool perfekt
funktioniert aber ich komme nicht dahin
verrechnung nicht möglich der
kreditkarte nicht möglich per paypal
nicht möglich ich kann das nicht kaufen
ich kann es für euch nicht richtig
testen und die kostenlose version bringt
überhaupt nicht völlig wirklich komplett
schlecht und scheiße hat mich übelst
ableger ich dachte wirklich dass wir
jetzt das eine produkt was mal richtig
geil ist ja was ist kriegs nicht mehr in
schmutz jetzt so langsam kommen wir
endlich in die bereiche wo wir mit
richtig ordentlichen firmenwerten zu tun
haben also nicht dass 400-500 600.000
sich ordentlich wäre aber jetzt knallt's
richtig eigentlich gar nicht aus der
aktuellen staffel aber gut in
kombination mit dem like tisch grundriss
in lebensgröße angefragt hatten sie
300.000 euro für 20 prozent bekommen
haben sie 300.000 euro für 25,1 prozent
von carsten maschmeyer und judith
williams was einem wert von 1 195
millionen euro macht und auch schon
bevor ich das ganze jetzt getestet habe
muss ich sagen dass ich die idee
unheimlich nice finde fehlplanung in
neubauten sind so ziemlich das
schlimmste was man sich vorstellen kann
weil sie einfach mit unheimlich riesigen
kosten riesigem aufwand und einer menge
kopfschmerzen verbunden sind aber was
ist grundriss in lebensgröße eigentlich
auch da wieder ein ziemlich gut gewählte
name es ist nämlich möglich mit
grundriss in lebensgröße den geplanten
grundriss für neu baut neue häuser neue
wohnungen im echten leben anschauen und
durchlaufen zu können bevor irgendwas
gebaut ist wenn das ganze jetzt auch
noch so funktioniert und so gut ist wie
ich mir das vorstelle dann ist das für
mich jetzt schon ein absolutes unding
produkt aber auch das haben wir uns
natürlich in echt angeschaut
erwartet hat uns eine über 200
quadratmeter große halle die fettesten
projektoren an der decke und vor allem
was mir vorher überhaupt nicht bewusst
waren echte
[Musik]
nach einem absolut epischen intro in dem
der grundriss auf die fläche geladen
wurde hat man also die möglichkeit alle
räume tatsächlich zu betreten und jetzt
stehen wir quasi im brahms 1 punkten und
können es auch so versetzen und gucken
ob der abstand zum fernseher vernünftig
passt sich aber wirklich auf ein sofa
setzen zu können oder schon vor dem bau
die küche zu testen ist wirklich gold
wert apropos küche neben der halle mit
dem grundriss gibt es auch viele andere
coole dinge zu entdecken wie zum
beispiel einen 3d küchenplaner haben bei
dem man sich mit kleinen bausteinen
super unkompliziert in echtzeit seine
traumküche zusammenstellen und
visualisieren kann also tatsächlich ist
es so dass ich wirklich das gefühl hat
mir das besser vorstellen zu können als
wäre es jetzt nur auf dem papier gerade
weil ihre sachen mit rein stellt und so
wir haben als wir haben die teilen die
häuser mietwohnungen mehrfamilienhäuser
briefen willen eine us- angeschaut haben
und das ist möglich also ich muss schon
sagen das lässt mich wirklich die
grundrisse wirklich in 3d zu sehen
anfassen zu können ist was völlig
anderes und ich glaube das ist die
einzige option das wirklich vernünftig
zu visualisieren durch den plan laufen
zu können ohne dass das haus gebaut ist
und dinge zu verändern hin und her zu
schieben und zu gucken ob alles so ist
wie man sich das vorstellt also ich
finde es ist eine absolute 10 von 10 für
sich ein eigenheim zu bauen ist eine
entscheidung die man vermutlich oder
bestenfalls einmal im leben trifft da
soll dann auch alles passen und genau um
dann die richtigen entscheidungen zu
treffen ist das hier richtig richtig
coole option mega kommen wir jetzt zum
letzten produkt dieses videos und damit
dem most fahne projekt mit dem größten
firmenwert der staffel 11 dass sich
guido nennt und eine quetsch ware titan
fleisch ist eine kutschfahrt titan
trinkflasche wer zur hölle braucht das
und was ist das eigentlich das schauen
uns jetzt mal gemeinsam haben angefragt
hatten sie 380.000 euro und wären bereit
gewesen 12 prozent ihrer firma dafür
abzugeben bekommen haben sie 380.000
euro und haben dafür 20 prozent an
carsten maschmeyer und georg kofler
abgegeben schluss mit plastik im wasser
das sagt schon relativ viel über das
produkt aus ketsch war leichtgewicht
reines wasser ein inneres aus reinem
titan viele sportler greifen auf plastik
trinkflasche zurück bei sie quetsch da
sind leute auf dem fahrrad greifen
schnell danach spritzen sich damit was
in den mund mann ca
taxis auf diesen pkk humor ab das
problem ist aber dass dadurch micro
plastik ablagerungen mit ins wasser
kommen die flaschen häufig so einen
leichten geschmack haben und genau hier
soll diese flasche abhilfe schaffen was
mich allerdings gewundert hat direkt
beim auspacken ja ich sehe die titanen
beschichtung auf der innenseite der
flasche im deckel finden wir aber nichts
auf der verpackung hier steht drauf ja
ist komplett dpa frei 100% silikon alles
easy also korrigiert mich in den
kommentaren wenn ich falsch liege aber
warum muss die innenseite titan sein
wenn ihr deckel auch 100% dpa
schadstofffrei was auch immer frei ist
hätte da nicht die ganze flasche aus
diesem plastik und silikon sein können
dadurch auch quetsch war oder ist das
titan in der flasche nur sehr gut für
marketing und mega cool weil sie es
hinbekommen haben also irgendwas passt
da für mich nicht ganz zusammen ich weiß
nicht ich würde darauf hoffen dass
antwort von der firma kommt denn sie
können es uns mit absoluter sicherheit
sagen gerade durch mit der springseil
einheit ein paar produkte vorher jetzt
brauche ich ein bisschen wasser guido 39
euro lohnt ist sich
sehr schön geformter strahl level noch
los super games quechua und tatsächlich
schmecke ich nichts also das wasser
schmeckt sowie aus der flasche wo ich es
vorher ausgefüllt habe natürlich kommt
das wasser war ein gefällt habe aus
einer glasflasche finde ich super also
tatsächlich ist die flasche für mich ein
richtig gutes produkt das ich sagen muss
findet flaschen tatsächlich echt schön
wenig aber egal also ob wohl zu teuer
ist finde ich richtig bei dem deckel bin
ich immer noch skeptisch aber ich bin
mir sicher wir werden darauf auch noch
eine antwort finden ich hatte mein auto
vergessen naja wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann lass mir gerne ein
leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren um keine der weiteren tollen
ich teste höhle der löwen produkte
testen folgen zu verpassen wir sehen uns
in den nächsten tagen schon wieder macht
es gut